hello how are you greeting cristian
casares one day after thousands of
supporters of president da notte trump
demonstrated in washington and stormed
into the capitol in protest los
hierba
[Music]
hello how are you greeting cristian
casares one day after  that thousands of
supporters of president da notte trump
demonstrated in washington they stormed
inside the capitol in protest
of the election results the fbi and
other federal agencies continue to
investigate and seek to identify
some of the protesters who
vandalized the legislative building it was
confirmed that four people died
including a woman who suffered
gunshot wounds this morning, congress
certified job airén as the president-
elect while the
social networks of the president of donald trump
have been stopped and definitely by
facebook and instagram and his twitter account is
still blocked by both barén
As Nevada State Legislators
Called  In fact, an attack on the
country's democracy, the
basketball player with a visa although Lens
appeared in court this morning where he
is accused of driving drunk and causing a
fatal accident. A young man faces
charges of driving under the influence of
alcohol and  of reckless driving
resulting in death documents also
reveal that collins has a history
of traffic violations
the police report revealed that the young man was driving
at speeds
over 85 miles per hour and under
the influence of alcohol when he collided with
erc echevería's car  A 52-year-old
near Fort Apache and Blue Demon
streets died in the accident. A
fire completely consumed a
condominium complex under
construction in the northwest valley
near Sky Point streets and was already blazing just
after midnight Thursday.
and the smoke managed to be so
intense that they could be seen from
miles behind although no one was injured
at least 65 firefighters ay  They were unable to put out
the fire and due to the delicate state
of the structure, the investigation
has not been completed, so the
cause of the incident is unknown. The damage is estimated
at almost half a million dollars and I
paid close attention if you are looking for a
job. Resorts World  is
recruiting for its grand opening this
coming summer the company says more
than 75,000 people have already applied
and the virtual interviews have
gone very well the public is reminded
there are still a variety of
open positions visit news now
dotcom for more  details today's mayor
carmen
her annual report on the state of
the city is anticipated to detail her
vision for next year and post-
pandemic the report will be virtual and
community members are invited to
join the conversation by submitting
questions using the  hashtag stay the
avengers and it is anticipated there will be a lot of
traffic in the area near or around the
new fast food restaurant  ask for check
soleil at the trust in fort apache and after
its opening today this is the
tenth location of the
restaurant chain and although its dining room
will not be open for now customers can
pick up their food at the entrance or through the
self-service window  and a
former web gamer if he takes his
talents from the octagon to the streets of
las vegas
julie gomez is now a new agent with
the metropolitan police department
and is stationed at the
south center valley station com is a
renowned professional athlete from  martial
arts since 2007 now he has
a record of 9 fights won and 5
lost he is also the co-founder of the
academy cobra falls here in the valley
now a look at the weather conditions
in our region for today
a cloudy day is expected with the
high temperature reaching 60 degrees
the cold will return during this
weekend when temperatures are expected to
drop after you can change
your coat for something  or lighter for a
single moment when temperatures
rise to 60 degrees and no sign
of rain for the next week I'm
Cristian Casares and this is your
igloo nao day report in Spanish
[Music]